こんにちははじめ社長ですはい昔から見てる方
この部屋見覚えないでしょうか
そう私この度引越しをさせていただきました
nasa が東京にするとは思わなかったですね
そうです
町から東京に引っ越させていただきます
ホモだよーん嘘でや東京なら引っ越せないんですけどやっぱちょっといろいろ用事が
あって今日からここで福岡の地で福岡で今日から頑張って行こうと思いますぅ依存お
互いにもうそうです
静岡でございますで引っ越したつってもうあんまりアレでしょ
おまめちゃんだと思うんですけど例のレオ
あれです同じ会社のお部屋でございますあー引っ越せっても僕はなく学生のプランに
入っているので引越しにはあんまりお金がかからない感じになっているんで
マイナーチェンジと言いますか触れ呼ばれ放会社から同じ会社に移った感じでござい
ます金も全部付いてるんですごい
引っ越しああだったんですけどまあそこそこ時間もかかり
ました
どうですかマイセンでた場所を結構山形にあって近くにコンビニもすればもなかったし
毎日もすごいもう富士山之上感じだったんですよ
をエア探せたらまあまあいい場所だったね今回そこに移動させていただきました
別に退去させられたとかそういうわけじゃないからぐぞうも一回もいけないからね
勘違いしないでね
昔住んでた形と同じ部屋にまた戻ってきました
こっちのが落ち着けしねえ
その次すごい初心に帰って気分でございますよ
こんだけ上がる奴からこれぐらいくろっけあったり
ちょっと暗くなったりバックラーにあったりっていうまあいろいろ
照明もしっかり撮影用の正念場免税
大分大代目で環境的にはバッチリもう品希望とかせる部屋にきたつもりなんでは昨日の
雨で一気にちょっと
壁行っちゃったんですけど
まあ
新しい部屋に移動したということで外把握よろしくお願いします
それだけの動画じゃつまらないんで
質問コーナーというか中リクエストとかですねコメント欄にぜひ僕に記事たいこととか
びっくりしたと買った
みてくださいそれに応える動画を出すんでリクエストとかできるだけ短い
リクエストお願いします自分で自分で腹殴ってくださいとかを靴下抜いてくださいとか
なんかすぐできるリクエストなら本当に余裕があればやろうと思うんでぜひコメント
ランディ
待ってマースまたねっ
昔の部屋の感じで頑張っていこうと思います
じゃあ
入っていっ